this has been the most fun I've had in
decades Ames is disarmingly unflappable
he's got that down home charm he's
essentially the new Mr Nobody it's out
with the old and in with the new order
the days were one man behind the wheel
of the car can make a difference are
over
I think he understands what a forced
dumb is to be reckoned with everyone
becomes family it's like a cult with
cars AMC's Dom is this manipulator this
master Puppeteer bring God's eye on life
yes sir
find his family I love the firework I
feel like I'm not earning my paycheck
until this might happen
[Music]
I've never been a part of something
quite like this I feel like I'm living a
dream